y terminé justo aquí en Singapur,
5 semanas después,
mucho menos descompensada que ahora.
Y fue una revelación.
Navegamos 5 mares,
2 océanos, 9 puertos
y aprendí mucho sobre el transporte.
Y una de las primeras cosas que me sorprendieron
cuando llegué a bordo del Kendal
fue, ¿dónde está la gente?
Tengo amigos en la Armada que me dicen
que viajan con 1000 marineros a la vez,
pero en el Kendal hay solo 21 tripulantes.
Se debe a que el transporte marítimo es muy eficiente.
El uso de contenedores ha hecho que sea muy eficiente.
Hoy las naves están automatizadas.
Pueden operar con tripulaciones pequeñas.
Pero eso también significa que, en palabras
de un capellán de puerto que conocí una vez,
el marinero medio que encontrarán
en un barco de contenedores o está cansado o agotado,
porque el ritmo del transporte moderno
es bastante agotador para lo que en el transporte se llama
su "elemento humano",
una frase extraña que no parecen advertir
que suena un poco inhumana.
La mayoría de los marineros que trabajan en barcos de contenedores
a menudo pasan menos de 2 horas en el puerto.
No tienen tiempo para relajarse.
Están en el mar durante meses,
e incluso cuando están a bordo,
no tienen acceso a lo que
un niño de 5 años daría por descontado, Internet.
Otra cosa que me sorprendió a bordo del Kendal
fueron mis compañeros
—no la reina, no sé por qué me pusieron debajo de su retrato—.
Alrededor de la mesa de comedor del salón de oficiales
estaba sentada al lado de un birmano,
y frente a un rumano, un moldavo, un indio.
En la otra mesa había un chino,
y en la sala de la tripulación, todos eran filipinos.
Era una nave normal de trabajo.
¿Cómo es posible?
Debido a los drásticos cambios
que experimentó el transporte en los últimos 60 años,
algo que pasó inadvertido para el público
fue el llamado "registro abierto",
o "bandera de conveniencia".
Los barcos pueden llevar la bandera de cualquier nación
que provea un registro de bandera.
Pueden conseguir bandera de una nación sin salida al mar
como Bolivia, Mongolia
o Corea del Norte, aunque no sea muy popular.
(Risas)
Por eso tenemos esos barcos multinacionales
mundiales, con tripulación móvil.
Y eso me sorprendió.
Y cuando llegamos a aguas piratas,
en el estrecho de Bab-el-Mandeb y en el Océano Índico,
el barco cambió.
Y eso también fue sorprendente, porque, de repente,
me di cuenta, cuando me lo dijo el capitán,
de que fue una locura eso de entrar
en aguas piratas en un barco de contenedores.
Ya no podíamos permanecer en cubierta.
Había 2 turnos de guardia.
En ese momento habían secuestrado a esos 544 marineros,
y algunos fueron tomados como rehenes durante años
por la naturaleza del transporte y la bandera de conveniencia.
No todos, pero algunos lo eran,
porque para una minoría de propietarios de buques inescrupulosos,
puede ser fácil ocultarse detrás
del anonimato que ofrecen algunas banderas de conveniencia.
¿Qué más oculta nuestra ignorancia sobre el mar?
Bueno, si salen al mar en un barco
o en un crucero, y miran la chimenea,
verán un humo muy negro.
Y eso se debe a que los barcos
tienen márgenes muy estrechos y quieren combustible barato,
por eso usan algo llamado fuelóleo
que me describieron en el sector petrolero
como la escoria de la refinería,
solo un paso encima del asfalto.
Y el transporte marítimo es el método más ecológico.
En materia de emisiones de carbono
emite una milésima parte respecto de la aviación
y cerca de un décimo del transporte terrestre.
Pero no es benigno, porque hay mucho transporte marítimo.
Las emisiones del transporte marítimo son del 3 % al 4 %,
casi igual que la aviación.
Y si ponen las emisiones del transporte marítimo
en una lista con las emisiones de carbono por países,
estaría en 6° lugar,
cerca de Alemania.
Se calculó en 2009 que los 15 barcos más grandes
contaminan en términos de partículas, hollín
y gases nocivos
tanto como todos los autos del mundo.
Y la buena noticia es que
la gente está hablando de un transporte marítimo sustentable.
Hay iniciativas interesantes.
Pero ¿por qué ha demorado tanto?
¿Cuándo empezaremos a hablar y pensar
en las millas marítimas, al igual que en las millas aéreas?
También viajé a Cape Cod para ver
la difícil situación de la ballena franca del Atlántico Norte,
porque esto para mí fue una de las cosas más sorprendentes
del tiempo que pasé en el mar,
y algo que me ha hecho reflexionar.
Conocemos el impacto del hombre sobre el océano
en materia de pesca y sobrepesca,
pero no sabemos mucho sobre
lo que está sucediendo bajo el agua.
De hecho, el transporte marítimo juega un papel importante
porque su ruido ha contribuido
a dañar los hábitats acústicos de las criaturas del océano.
La luz no penetra bajo la superficie del agua,
por eso los animales marinos como las ballenas, los delfines
y 800 especies de peces
se comunican con el sonido.
Y una ballena franca del Atlántico Norte
puede transmitir a través de cientos de kilómetros.
La jorobada puede transmitir un sonido
por todo el océano.
Pero un superpetrolero también puede ser escuchado
en todo el océano,
y como el ruido que hacen las hélices bajo el agua
a veces tiene la misma frecuencia que usan las ballenas,
entonces pueden dañar su hábitat acústico,
el cual necesitan para reproducirse,
para encontrar alimentos,
para encontrar pareja.
Y el hábitat acústico de la ballena franca del Atlántico Norte
se ha reducido en un 90 %.
Pero aún no hay leyes que regulen la contaminación acústica.
Y cuando llegué a Singapur,
pido disculpas por esto, pero no quería bajar de mi barco.
Me encantó estar a bordo del Kendal.
La tripulación me trató muy bien,
el capitán era locuaz y entretenido,
y con gusto habría firmado por otras 5 semanas.
También por esto el capitán dijo
que estaba loca de solo pensarlo.
Pero no estaba allí 9 meses por vez
como los marinos filipinos,
que, cuando les pedí que me describieran su trabajo,
dijeron "dinero por nostalgia".
Tenían buenos salarios,
pero sus vidas siguen siendo aisladas y difíciles
en un ambiente peligroso y a menudo difícil.
Pero cuando llego a esta parte, siento una ambigüedad,
porque quiero saludar a esos marineros
que nos dan el 90 % de todo
y a cambio reciben muy poco reconocimiento.
Quiero saludar a los 100 000 barcos
que están en altamar
haciendo ese trabajo, yendo y viniendo
cada día, trayéndonos lo que necesitamos.
Pero también quiero que el transporte marítimo
y nosotros, el público, que sabemos muy poco de esto,
controlemos un poco más,
que sea un poco más transparente,
que tenga un 90 % de transparencia.
Porque creo que todos podríamos beneficiarnos
de hacer algo muy simple,
que es aprender a ver el mar.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)